wir werden jetzt ein bisschen unter der
erde
wir gehen jetzt auf jeden fall
trampolinspringen und rutsche fahren und
alles unter der erde also mit höhen und
licht sondern auf jeden fall mehr
wir gehen jetzt trampolinspringen höhe
wir sind doch nicht trampolinspringen
wir sind ihm eine stunde zu früh hier
jedenfalls warten jetzt gerade von
sachsen und danach gehen wir gleich
klappen schwimmen wir gehen jetzt rein
ich fühl mich sowie zum hohen alter ist
halt einfach übelsten als mannschaft
heftig
gehen wir gleich trampolinspringen da
unten jetzt einfach richtig weit runter
wir sind jetzt gerade in den krebs
behindert springt das trampolin mäßig
aber irgendwie auch nicht wahrscheinlich
ein break wir sind gerade schon ein
bisschen allerdings gesprungen aber ich
glaube da hat man nicht so viel gesehen
war das nicht einfach nicht wie
anstrengend es auch ist man heute
einfach so 1000 jahre hoch er ist das
wirklich der richtige weg alter da sind
wir ganz einfach hoch gelaufen ist
einfach so richtig
mehr oder wenig überwältigen ich bin
total
erstaunlich viele freunde was damit max
los
zwischen medlock
gestört wir waren rath springen halten
wir waren gerade auf jeden fall unten
springen das ist schon anstrengend
das hat mir viel spaß gemacht das ist
anstrengend irgendwie bei mir sind auch
die kompletten junge das licht das ist
auch so helmes ab wir sind jetzt wieder
draußen an der schönen sonne werden
jetzt denke ich zum strand fahren
erstmals fällt erstmals hotel fahren wir
sind jetzt im hotel angekommen und es
ist einfach so ich liebe solche hotels
so in dem wir gerade sind ich gebe euch
mal eine ganz kurze ruhm tue
hallo das hier ist der eingangsbereich
hier ist spiegelschrank
dazu haben wir hier noch den ausblick
sind keine stütze und würde ich euch
diese wundervolle aussicht hier draußen
zeigen aber ich denke ihr seht das auch
so bis in mein bett wir liegen jetzt
hier und das macht es noch
also ich hätte lust was essen zu gehen
ich muss nie diskutiert
also ich glaube wir werden jetzt erstmal
kleinen tricks zum strand machen wir
sind gerade am strand angekommen so
sieht das hier aus
das ist der stand es gibt keinen strand
hier bis halt echt gegen den komisch uns
wurde gesagt dass hier der strand ist
wirklich eigentlich exakt genau hier und
wir sind hier hingefahren und was ist
hier eine alte tankstelle die nicht mehr
in betrieb ist wir fahren zurück zum
hotel